foreign  [Music]  okay so first off I just want to say I  get it you get what  High School Kamala Kamala another  adventure shirt cute she thinks I'm some  kind of weirdo you are a weirdo boys  excuse me yeah yeah you're kind of on my  shirt sorry  but you're staring out the window in  your little fantasy land  come on hey already really come on like  do I have to figure out my whole future  before lunch  be there right I spend too much time  in Fantasyland  that is not you  it's not really the brown girls from  Jersey City to save the world  that's the fantasy too  [Music]  does something happen to you no why did  you hear something come on  I feel like  Cosmic  [Music]  I always thought I wanted this kind of  life  [Music]  but I never imagined any of this do you  even know what you are  [Music]  thank you